mrs. Bush Jenna Bush's rejoin you from
the National Book Festival have we
become a nation of readers well I hope
we're a nation of readers and I think
today it certainly looks like it on the
National Mall the National Book Festival
it attracts over a hundred thousand
people and I hope that many will come
today and come down here and meet their
favorite authors sure there are a lot of
people that don't read obviously we know
from a report that the National
Endowment for the Arts did a study that
they did that say there's a literacy in
America not illiteracy not people who
don't know how to read but people who
know how to read but don't and one of
the things one of the reasons we have a
National Book Festival and one of the
things that both Jenna and I've worked
on our whole lives really is making sure
people do read because reading and being
able to read well and comprehend is such
a huge advantage for people people who
can do that can get a job and can live a
much more successful life than people
who can't read in general from your
perspective yes I mean I think we are
working in schools teaching language
arts in English so is a biased English
teacher I hope we are I think you know
the perspective that adults must do
whether you're parents or teachers or
librarians or just role models is find
books that are interesting to kids
don't just feed the literature that you
loved as a child down their throats but
find things that interest them and I
found especially with boys that graphic
novels which are very popular in schools
now and comics and RL Stein who is the
god of scary stories for little boys as
long as my kids are reading I think
we're a nation of readers and I think
literacy as books are becoming more and
more popular in schools what were your
reading habits when the girls were young
for you and your husband well we've
always read I mean I'm a librarian of
course I've read since I learned to read
my mother was a huge reader and read to
me before I knew how to read and then
George and I both read to Jenna and
Barbara and now we trade books Jenna and
Barbara and I do recommend our favorite
books to each other and so it really is
intergenerational it's very important
for parents to let children know that
reading is important and to spend those
few years those just brief years that
you have when you have little children
at home before they go to school spend
time with them with your arm around them
reading to them it's there's no more
important time and it's something that
children will grow up and remember and
it's a wonderful memory for parents as
well remembering what it was like to
share those funny dr. Seuss books with
their kids or Curious George or all
those others that are classics of
American literature let me ask you about
the collaborative effort that you had in
writing the book what was it like for
you and and I know you were involved in
the process it was a lot of fun it was
really interesting you know after 26
years of having a relationship as a
mother
daughter and that type of relationship
to work creatively with my mom because
it's a relationship and you don't get to
experience very often but it was we had
a great time and I think really we
bounced ideas off of each other
often and it happened really naturally
and organically and it's based on
stories that she told me because you
know what books are especially you know
fiction and nonfiction or great stories
and if they didn't read they were
telling us stories and of her time
teaching because as little girls we were
fascinated with what it would be like to
be teachers have you thought about
whether you and the president will
collaborate on a book I think we will
probably write books after we leave I
mean I'm not saying for sure but I don't
know if we'll work together on one but
that's not a bad idea what about your
experiences will you write a book about
being first lady well I don't know that
for sure but I hope so this book
festival now in its eighth year will it
continue I don't know I think that I
think that it will at such an
institution people love it so many
people come out I think authors love to
be here on the National Mall they love
to meet each other and be together here
and so I hope that it will continue and
I think it will I believe it's a become
an institution in Washington and so I I
want to encourage you ever comes after
us to pay attention to it and make sure
the National Book Festival continues
what have you learned during this
process in organizing this with the
Library of Congress well I've learned
how fabulous our Library of Congress is
I don't know people really are aware if
most Americans are aware that our
Library of Congress is the largest
library in the world and they have a
copy of everything that's published in
the United States and nearly everything
that's published worldwide they're
working right now on a digital library
to put every single thing in the Library
of Congress on the web digitally which
will be really a wonderful treasure for
generations after this to be able to
access everything that's here but I also
have learned that people love books that
they love to come down to meet their
favorite authors that they're willing to
stand in line
get a autograph from their favorite
writers that they want to hear stories
just like Jenna said I think we all know
that all of us love a good story and
that's what I think this really proves
that people want to come here great
stories from our great American writers
and you touched on this earlier but what
makes a good book what makes a good
story well anything that I think is
human in a way that there are ways we
can relate to it it could be a true
story a story of real people or a story
of real animals or a story of something
that is real in our world or it could be
totally imaginary totally fantasy and
totally fiction I think what makes a
good story is a story that that somehow
people can relate to as they read it
even if it's total fantasy or fiction
like for instance the great Harry Potter
books that are totally fantasy but
they're fascinating stories for me I
mean I think it depends on the person I
mean I think real characters characters
that we can relate with characters that
you can see yourself in or our
characters that can make you lose
yourself you know I mean it depends on
the person though last question for you
in a couple of months you will be
leaving Washington going back to Texas
what's next for you and what has the
last eight years meant to you well it's
been unbelievable privilege to be here
and to be in Washington and to represent
the people of the United States like
I've had the chance to do representing
them overseas and in a lot of countries
around the world I'll continue to work
on the same things I've always worked on
on libraries and literacy I'm still the
honorary ambassador for the UN decade of
literacy and so I'll continue to work
with the UN focusing on the 34 countries
around the world that have the highest
rates of illiteracy because I believe
that literacy worldwide and especially
for girls and women who are the ones
most often denied education that
literacy worldwide will go a long way to
solving a lot of our problems
and will you write another book I hope
so I mean right now I'm teaching but
kids say the most inspiring things so I
hope I continue to teach and write and
see Jenna Bush mrs. Bush thank you for
your state thanks Trish I did